happy
monday after thanksgiving i hope you
guys had a good break
um uh we are are back
in action here on uh acids and bases
second lecture on acid bases um uh
before
we get into that there's a celebration
happening on friday
you know that's why we're all feeling
like a little extra goodness right now
because we know there's a third midterm
coming up friday in this class
right and that's nothing but excitement
here's a concept map that i made
for exam three this helps you sort of
see the kinds of problems
right that you can get the topics that
we've covered
and how it's all flowed and connected
together right so here are the quizzes
there's the
optional one oh you could still do it
so please if you want to do the 8.5 and
and get that
graded and then if it's higher than your
lowest quiz we'll swap it in for that
and you still get to drop one please do
that and hand it in
by tomorrow's recitation there's that
one there's quiz
uh there's the other two quizzes and
here are the
uh p sets and the goodie bags all this
is the
the kinds of problems this has the the
the practice problems
um and the topics that we want you to
know about for friday oh
and also on wednesday
instead of introducing a new topic that
you won't be tested on
i'd prefer just to kind of talk about
these topics so that's what i'm going to
do on wednesday
and we'll do some additional problems
and kind of review
okay but we still got to get through
the rest of acids and bases now
this is where we left off this
way of thinking about acids and bases is
where we left off
on wednesday and and this is the
arrhenius oh cevante
oh sfonte he was the first remember
for thousands this is bitter put it in
that category this is sour
right acid base acid and there were ways
that people
categorized acids and bases for a long
time but nobody really started to try to
understand them at the atomic scale
until cevante came along and said look
it's all about the h plus and the o h
minus
right so so acids and and this is what
we talked about on wednesday
acids are donating h plus ions
protons into solution into water and
bases are donating
o h minus adding more of those types of
ions
into the water and that's what makes
them have the properties they have
okay now um
so so if you have so let's see so
h uh i'm going to just write this one on
the board
because we're going to talk about these
two reactions plus h2o
and remember um the water is just a kind
of spectator there
um it's a liquid it's everywhere it's
the thing you're dissolving in it's the
solvent
that's the water now so you don't
include it
you know in in these if it's just a
liquid that's a solvent that you're
dissolving something it's not what you
include
in things like uh equilibrium constant
expressions
um okay so that's gonna be oh but these
guys these are dissolved
in the liquid right these are the ions
plus c
l minus now
okay now in this particular case
you can write the equilibrium constant
right and that's the acid it's also
something that the acid dissociation
constant remember
we have the solubility product constant
we also can write the ka
right so ka for this would be
following our normal k equilibrium
constant procedure
it would look something like this right
now
here's the thing for this particular
reaction of um for this particular
dissociation of hcl
of this acid remember it's an acid
because it's giving us
h plus oh h plus doesn't stage plus
remember that's also we talked about
wednesday h plus
is actually h3o plus but the h plus is
not stable in pure water
but sometimes actually very often you'll
see it in textbooks as well you'll see
it just written as h
plus but we know that it's the same
thing
h3o if it's in water it's h3o plus right
okay so don't let but this is something
like 10 to the sixth
that's huge that equilibrium
is so far over that equilibrium is so
far
over given this enormous equilibrium
constant
that we we often will say that this
reaction has gone to completion
now we know that it's not infinite right
so it hasn't
technically there's still a little arrow
going that way
right right so but but uh and so
but since it's so much almost
to completion you'll often also see it
written with just one arrow
all right so i want to make that clear
but we know that it's an equilibrium
this is found in equilibrium so there's
still a little bit happening the other
way
but just so little all right so you'll
often see that
going to completion okay good
getting us back into the mood
now for the base
we could have n a o h let's do that one
plus h 2 o
goes to n a plus
in solution plus o h minus and this is
the arrhenius
acid base definition goes in tight and
you could write a similar expression for
the base
uh and a plus
o h minus and that's going to
go over naoh now this is
also very
large so this hot now these are both
strong
and we're going to come back to this at
the end of the lecture i want to talk
about what makes an acid or base strong
or weak these are both strong and and
just as a little preview to where we're
getting
that's because they dissociate so much
so this also
has a very high kb kb because we're
talking about a base
k b k a k b right
oh some people don't like these large
exponents these
large are small 10 to the minus fifth 10
to the positive
fifth and so we take the log well you
can take the log of
of these and then you'll get like a pkb
right
or pkb which is the power
of that so log of kb
would be low right
would be low if this is going to be high
then minus the log of the power that is
going to be low so you can talk about
pkb
kb ka pka
it's all just thinking about these
equilibrium constants and we'll come
back to this in a second
if i had a question for you if i said
okay
how would you use this if i said
that i've got a point i'm going to give
you a problem now
0.05 moles per liter
of naoh and i and i asked you
what's the ph well you can do it now
all right why because i've just told you
it's just it's it's an almost fully
dissociated
base so the the equilibrium constant for
that
dissociation of that base is very very
high means it lies very far over to the
right
so basically what does that mean if i've
got .05 moles per liter
starting out it's mostly to sodium state
it's in tight
so so i've got 0.05 moles per liter
of n a plus and o h minus
all right okay but the o h minus is what
matters
so full dissociation
oh we're going to do this because i want
to be
precise here put that in quotes it's
almost full
means that i have 0.05 moles per liter
of o h minus by the way and in a plus
but any plus is a spectator in terms of
the ph it's not going to change the ph
right the n8 plus is sitting
over the o-h will all right and and so
now we go back to these these k's we
know
right we know that the equilibrium
constant of pure water
is equal to
the concentration of h plus in solution
which is h3o plus
times o h minus and that that's equal to
10 to the minus 14.
right that's another thing that we
talked about on
wednesday so so if that's true
if the which it is at 25c the
equilibrium constant for water which is
the remember water can be either one
it's this times this
and we know what this is now you know
what that is
right and if you know it h plus if the
concentration of h plus is known
then the ph power of the p
is the minus log the ph of that
is something you can calculate and so
the ph
winds up here being 12.7
right that's the kind of thing that you
can
have fun with you dissolve some nao some
base
and you can measure a ph or a poh if you
wanted
all stuff we talked about last week
okay but now we move on and and now
we're gonna
introduce the next definition of acids
and bases by first talking about
what happens when you mix them together
right these are not mixing together yet
they're just you know a base dissolves
in water and acid dissolves in water
but what if i had an acid and a base
and i mix them together okay
well so if i did that then
i would have hcl plus
n-a-o-h now i'm just gonna
i'm not i'm not gonna include the water
it's there on the left and it's gonna be
there on the right
i'm just gonna write all these ions down
that happen right so you're going to get
oh you're going to get h plus oh we know
it's h3o plus
plus uh cl minus
plus uh na plus
okay these are all dissolved in water
i'm emphasizing that
with the little aqueous subscripts
and you can see what's going to happen
now right so if i have these there
but look at this the n a plus and the cl
minus boy do
but they see each other like well maybe
we could form some salt
maybe we can form some salt and then the
o h
and the h and those form water and so
you can get h2o
plus nacl and so what happens is what's
written there
is that when you when you mix an acid
with a base
you will get water and some salt now
remember salt is a general term
right for uh these these cations and
anions
right coming together in a solid so uh
okay now here's the thing though all
right so this was
the acid and i'm writing this explicitly
because you'll see
and this was the base
and because what is neutralization well
now
you can think you think about it in
terms of ph i i had something with maybe
a low ph or maybe a high ph
and i want it to become neutral
neutral would be if i'm in pure water kw
is 10 minus 14
neutral would be it's the same acid and
base
ratio so these are each 10 to the minus
seventh ph seven
neutral right there's no excess of
protons or oh minuses
right so so if there's no excess it's
neutral so neutralization
is basically the act of making it
neutral so i had something that gave a
lot of h pluses
and i got something that gave me it
gives me a lot of o h minuses
if i have the same amount of them right
then so they're equivalent then you can
you can make it neutral that's
neutralization okay
but see the thing is i can take hcl
and i can mix windex or ammonia
with it and neutralize it
and back then they're like but that
doesn't make any sense
but first of all because we don't have
windex yet
but second of all because windex doesn't
have any o h minus
goes in tight man so that got them
really thinking
right so if i take so let's take nh3
now so if i take nh3
if i take nh3 and i go like this
and h3 plus
hcl now this is not i'm not writing the
liquid dissociation of
the thing i'm mixing it acid
and something else that i know
neutralizes it and in fact what ends up
happening
is you get gazunty you get
this
and so what we know
is that this is
neutralizing it's taking
what's happening in this reaction what's
actually happening
what did the what did that base do
effectively
to neutralize hcl what it did is it took
h plus from the solution that's what it
did
right so nh3 in this reaction
nh3 takes
it takes h plus
from the solution
what did that's exactly hcl was like i
want to make it acidic
h plus h plus h plus and nh3 is like no
give me the h pluses you cannot make
this i'm neutralizing you
i'm taking your h pluses back if it
takes that then that's neutralizing
that's going to neutralize
the hcl as well
but see we have a problem because this
is not an oh donating molecule
but it still neutralizes and so we need
a broader definition
and that came from bronstead and lowry
and so this is another way of thinking
a more general way of thinking of acids
and bases
more general more correct because the
the the arrhenius definition does not
cover
classes of of molecules that are
that could be a base
and so in this way in the bronsted-lowry
definition
in the bronsted-lowry definition it's
all about the proton
so let me write that down here so in
bronstead and lowry
their definition
is that acid
and he did it by looking at acid
base neutralization reactions like i
just described actual base
neutralization
[Music]
i'm not going to write it because
there's no room reactions
is all about the proton transfer these
are proton
transfer reactions this is how they saw
acids and bases as exchanging a proton
taking it or giving it
that's what it's about right
and so in our sort of general uh uh you
know in the general
h a kind of lingo that we introduced you
would have
h a plus b
and that's gonna go to b
h plus plus a
minus that's an acid base
reaction and so you can see that these
are
this is a proton donor
this is a proton donor and this is
an acceptor
it's a donor h plus donor
h plus acceptor that defines them
according to bronson and larry as
acids and bases okay
okay well we can also okay so now let's
see let's now go back
so that's that's a broader definition
let's now go back to the ammonia
okay and what i want to do now is
instead of mixing it with an acid
to think about whether it trades a
proton i want to just dissolve it in
water
so now we know it's a base okay
so what happens so if i dissolve nh3
in h2o
i want to point something out here that
if i do this
and i get nh 4 plus
plus o h minus
that's the now i'm taking a base right
so there we had
there's the acid here's the base that's
the iranian space
and now i'm taking a bronsted-lowry base
right it took an h plus well
that means that this is a base but look
this okay this gave
a proton so this must be an acid
according to bronson
according to bronson lowry and and
similarly
over here we know that this is going to
give one
and i'm going to write that in a second
and this would love to accept one
so that's a base right and remember we
have a name for this
in the same reaction we have a name for
this this would be
the conjugate
right
those are conjugates that's why i'm
writing those
right so the there's a conjugate base
acid
conjugate acid base now we have a a
bronsted-lowry understanding of what
conjugate acid base means
it's just a proton transfer right
it's just a proton transfer now notice i
could take this
so i've taken this base and i've i've
i've
put it into a solution of water but i
could take this acid and do the same
thing
so if i do that i've got nh4 plus
and i'm going to put that in water now
okay so i've taken this out
and now i'm putting that acid into water
and if i do that
look what happens i get nh3
plus h3o plus
notice what happened well i've switched
acid that's my acid
but this took the proton so it must be a
base
right and over here i've got the base
and this must be an acid
proton transfer that's what's happening
here
conjugates now i took the base
and i got an acid but so this this tells
us that
water and it tells us what we said on
wednesday water can be both
notice water is an acid in the one hand
and a base on the other
that makes it amphoteric
so h2o can
be both it can take or give protons
and so it is amphoteric
just for fun if you were if you take the
conjugate
you know if you take any acid-base pair
and they're conjugates
you can also write out the kas and kb's
right and so if i take a conjugate
acid and base
well you know that you could write ka
right okay so let's write the acid
dissociation so so for that one
here it is ka is nh
is uh h3o plus okay i'm going to take
the bottom one
h3l plus times nh3
right concentrations divided by
nh4 plus
but if i took the base dissociation
constant from the conjugate
i'm taking the conjugates now right then
i would get
that it's uh okay it's o h minus
and nh4 plus
divided by uh nh3
and like i'm saying just for fun you can
now look at this you go ka times kb
ka times kb that's reassuring
that k a times kb is equal to
h3o plus
times o h minus and i mean
concentrations
which is kw
that is fun for the bronsted-lowry
acid-base conjugate nh4 plus
and h3 right okay
okay that's bronsted-lowry acids and
bases
here's a little recap here's a little
recap i'm not going to like read through
this in
in detail but i just wanted to give you
okay what have we done so far
we've talked about amphoteric we've
talked about conjugate acids and bases
these are now written
in the bronsted-lowry form right they
accept or give a proton
uh we've talked about the conjugate
acid-base pair
what i just drew an example of right
there uh neutralization reactions and
salt okay good these are some concepts
that we have covered that i would like
you to know about
now but there's a few more concepts that
we have to come back to
a few more concepts that we have to come
back to and it has to do with what i
started with
in the beginning i said let you know
these p these k's are huge so the
equilibrium if
an equilibrium constant lies is very
large then you know you're mostly making
product
right and so it's it's essentially to
completion
and and i also mentioned that those are
strong
strong acids strong bases strong acids
strong bases
why is an acid or base strong
or weak that's what i want to talk about
next
right and actually there are
what you know there really aren't that
many strong acids
or strong bases in fact they're mostly
here
these are really pretty much most of
them
minor exceptions i don't want to go into
but these are really if you think about
those your general category strong acid
strong bases
this is it why
why is that well it has to do
with what we've been talking about right
so those are strong acids
those are strong bases
it has to do with dissociation
it has to do with dissociation so
if i take hcl and i put it in water
it it almost completely dissociates
that's why it's a strong acid now
there's a
there's confusion around this
and i want to make that i want to make
it very clear there's a big distinction
i want to make
because if something is is a weak acid
meaning it's not one of these
what that means is it doesn't dissociate
very much
that's what it means it doesn't have
anything to do with concentration
right so so let's take a weak acid let's
take vinegar
right so if i take a weak acid
we see vinegar as ch3
cooh what's nice about writing them
out this i said why didn't you put the h
in there and make it ch4
and co2 or put the two two c's together
oftentimes you'll see molecules written
out this way because
this tells us a little bit of a hint
about connectivity
and for acids and bases it's actually
useful because
you see the h there that's the one
that's going to trade that's the
bronsted-lowry transfer h right so often
for acids and bases you'll see that
written out
in in this way makes it easier to think
about
and if i if i mix this into water then
what do i get well i'm going to get h3o
i'm going to write this down here
h3o plus that's an acid
right plus uh ch3coo minus
there's the h that came off proton
transfer
so why is it weak
well it's weak because here the acid
equilibrium constant is something like
10 to the minus fifth
so even if i have
you know a lot even if i had like one
mole per liter of this stuff
in solution it wouldn't most of it
wouldn't dissolve
in fact much less than a percent of
vinegar actually gives me
h3o plus all right amazing dog just
add more vinegar no no
because we're talking about
concentrations
right it's the concentration in that
water
that's i'm locked into that by this this
is an equilibrium constant
and it's talking about the concentration
that i get in the water
i'm stuck i can't be that that's how
much you dissociate
right that's how much you dissociate as
a concentration so
it's more acidic than water for sure
right it's a hundred times more acidic
than water
right 10 to the minus fifth but but it's
never going to be a strong acid because
i don't give very much of the protons
that's what so this is the key that i
want to make clear
this is the key okay now it's
very important it gets its own
board the strength of an acid
okay so acid
concentration
is not equal to
acid strength
more and more and more vinegar no
it doesn't it doesn't matter because
it's about dissociation
see this is about
this is a function of the solubility
so how much can i get in there we talked
about all that a lot already
that's a different thing solubility
the ksp how much of this can i dissolve
great
i can dissolve a lot of vinegar in water
and it doesn't crash out right that's
wonderful
doesn't make it a strong acid this
is about dissociation
right and so so if you think about
what makes an acid a strong acid
or for that or or a weak acid or what
the relative strengths of acids are and
the same holds for bases just the other
way around
it has to do with how easy it is
to take that h off
or add it on right that's what it has to
do with
and so if you look at for example if you
look at
just a little series
right if you look at a series there
even that the strong acids have
differences
they're all strong they go mostly to
completion
but if you think about it in terms of
what we just talked about
it's the acid strength
is going to go roughly
often opposite
trend as bond strength
that's of the
of the proton transfer of the h
right there's an h hcl
hbr hi which will be the strongest acid
of those three
right well we now know this must be
the strongest
right opposite
because this is going to be easier to
get the hydrogens off in solution
and you can think about the weak acids
in the same exact way these are the
strong acids this this holds for all
you know it's a proton transfer it's all
about the strength
of the proton right neutralization is a
proton transfer
the uh whether you make an acid strong
or how strong it depends on how many of
those protons go into solution
and uh and so you can look up charts
like this and i love looking at this
stuff
because it makes you think about the
chemistry right so here you go
you've got okay uh acid different acids
molecular formula all right structural
formula
kanji notice they're putting that h
there in blue
oh that's so helpful and you just look
at the blue h and you think about it
as dissociating just like bronsten and
larry did
you think about that as coming off and
then you think about the conjugate base
right that's formed on the other side
and then you go over here and you think
oh this tells me how much it's
it's coming up how often this tells me
the equilibrium
of putting this into solution but say
this is which one of these is going to
be weaker
or stronger right
well and what does that mean about the
bond strength
itself what does that mean about how
easy it is to dissociate we now know
and we can think about that and
understand that these are not
these may look similar these h's attach
to carbon or oxygen what's the
difference
big difference when you put them in
water
a lot more or a lot less might come off
changing the acid strength
the more that comes off the more the
dissociation is to the right
right and and the high oh
and and the and the lower right the the
higher this number because the
equilibrium moves over to the right
right and the less that comes off the
lower this equilibrium constant is
ka right the lower it is the higher the
pka
we don't like these these small tiny
numbers you take a minus log
and you talk about pks that's fine right
okay good this is the this is the kind
of fundamental
understanding of acids and bases that i
i want you guys to have
and and so you know if we go back to
neutralization
now you say well okay this is kind of
this makes sense right
we had a strong acid and strong base if
you had them equivalent you'd get a ph
of seven now you know if you had a
strong acid weak base weak acid strong
base
it's gonna this is fairly
self-explanatory less than seven or
greater than seven
and now you know also if it's a weak
acid and a weak base and you're
neutralizing these together
it would depend on the ka and kb because
it depends on how many
of those ions you put in solution or can
take out
and that's given by the ka and kb okay
good good so we can answer questions
we're now
armed to answer questions and like i
said i want to answer
we're going to do some problems on
wednesday we'll talk about the topics
that are going to be on exam
okay um but we can answer questions like
this
here we are talking about acids and
bases what if i mix
a bunch of them together and they've got
different ka so you think about this
what if i mix
all of these together can i get my ph
right so here's a question you have uh
one mole per liter of hcn
with that acid dissociation constant and
five moles per liter
of hno2 with that one
okay you write the dissociation
reactions and calculate the ph of the
solution
that's a good question right so let's
see now how would i answer it
well oh bronsted-lowry
i don't want to erase you but i have to
i have no choice
so let's answer that question i see
the way that we think about this it's
telling us what to do
write the dissociation reactions for
each species
okay so i'm going to write it down so i
have hcn
hcn right is going to go to
h plus plus c n minus
now ka for this is equal to
h plus oh boy did i drop my subscripts
times c n minus divided by
hcn
concentrations but we're back to soluble
solubility product days
right this is an equilibrium and so
it's going both ways but you know from
the coefficients here
right you know from those coefficients
that if i dissociate
you know x amount of this then that's
how much of this
and this that i make right so
so this so now i know right
that uh well okay ka
times if i just bring this over there
hcn
is equal to x squared where x
let's let x equal concentration of h
plus
which equals the concentration of c n
minus
been there done that right from the
solubility product
uh problems that we've done and so you
can get from this
that the concentration of h plus which
is also h3o plus
is equal to 2.5
times 10 to the minus 5
moles per liter good okay but you can
keep going
and
i'm not gonna do all the math but
you could go through the same exercise
with
hno2 so for hno2
you get uh that the concentration of
these ions that you get from that
dissociation
is around 2 times 10
to the minus 3 moles per liter and by
the way
maybe uh i got less than 10 to the minus
7th
out of these things maybe
but if i did then if i did
then i'd also need to take into account
pure water
right so from pure water we know
if you just had water by itself then
you'd have the concentration here is
10 to the minus seventh
moles per liter now but now you just
look at this you say okay i got my
answer because
i everything's a lot lower than this one
thing
so this is going to dominate i mix it
all together but you see
it doesn't matter the other things
aren't able
to dissociate nearly as many h plus ions
they're just not able to as hno2
so this dominates and you can just
calculate the ph from this you're going
to get like two three digits down
some effect but it's okay right from
this
you can get the ph and the ph
is equal to 1.35
that's it the the the total contribution
of h plus ions in that solution is
roughly given
by this contribution here okay
might not have been but it was in that
case
okay how about this one so here's
another
okay so so we could take another example
let's uh stay over here
okay so in this example i'm not i'm
barely giving you anything here
it seems like but i give you enough i've
got a 0.2 moles per liter solution of a
weak acid
and it's 9.4 percent dissociated
that's the key that's the key
because remember this is now we've
learned the bronsted-lowry definition
it's all about h plus in
or coming out that's what there it is
now i erase it though it's all about the
h plus so if i know 9.4
dissociated i know something about
what kind of acid that is right so if i
have now h a
plus h2o and that goes
to h3o plus i've switched back
plus a minus then
how much dissociated well 0.0.2 moles
per liter
times 0.094 right so
point zero point zero nine four that's
the
the percent is that right yes nine point
four percent
times zero point two moles per liter and
that equals
zero 0.019
ish right that's how much
h a h a
dissociated
what if i know that and i know my
reaction and i got the stoichiometric
coefficients from the reaction
then i also know how much h3o plus and a
minus formed
was it if that much dissociated then
that much formed
right it could because they're right
that's the reaction those are the
coefficients
and so i can get it all and i can
calculate ka
which equals 2 times ten
to the minus third
and you get the ph all i gave you was
how much of it dissociated
i didn't even tell you what acid it was
but that's okay because we now know
that this is what counts this
dissociation
how many of these h's per liter how many
of those go
into solution is what matters okay
now there's another thing that i want to
talk about and we'll do some more
you know a little bit more uh like i
said problems on wednesday
but there's one more thing i want you to
know about related to acids and bases
and that is um that you can have more
than one
all these examples if you go back to
this list
those all had one hydrogen that was
ever gonna leave let's say i mean okay
ever
maybe if you went up to the middle of
the sun or something you get those but
this is you know in normal conditions
these are the ones that are going to
leave and no more but you can have
molecules
like phosphoric acid where look at all
those protons
so here's acetic acid that's the one
that's willing to leave
those are not they're on the carbon way
too hard to get them off
this one okay in solution sure to a
certain extent
in in phosphoric acid i've got three
hydrogens
and so that's called a multiprotic acid
why
because protic proton how many protons
right it could be monoprotic
like the ones we've talked about or it
could be multiprotic
like phosphoric acid and so you know if
you think about this the way we now
think about
acids and bases we think about an
acid as a dissociation right with
some dissociation equilibrium constant
and so huh and so if you think about
phosphoric acid
h3po4
uh let's put the water in h2o
liquid and that goes to h2
po4 minus plus h3o plus
well the ka for this one is
so if i put the kas in here this one is
uh 7.5 times
10 to the minus 3. but see what happens
is now this one
has two more hydrogens that could come
off so you could write those
dissociation reactions as well
so h2 po4 minus
if you put that in solution which it is
then that could give you hpo4
two minus all right h2
h it's a proton transfer
minus 2 minus right
uh plus h3o plus
and there's one more plus one
more this
dissociation constant is much much
smaller 6.2
times 10 to the minus eight
and the third one is 4.2
times 10 to the minus 13th
so they're smaller but they happen and
that's important
and it can be very important it depends
on the molecule but in this case
it's not just the parent you know that
acid there that's losing a proton but
then
this one can also lose a proton it can
also be an acid
it just has an equilibrium that's not as
far over so it's not going to give as
many
uh h pluses into solution okay
it's important to know about and finally
the last thing i want you to know you
will not be uh tested on this but it's
important because
here's where we are here's where we are
arrhenius said
right before thanksgiving it's
all about the h plus and the o h minus
that got us really far got us through
thanksgiving
but then today we're like no it's got to
be more general it's
just proton transfer no don't tell me
about oh minus
it's just proton transfer and so
then comes lewis oh we know lewis
we've already talked a lot about lewis
lewis said why are you guys
all obsessed about protons and he said
it in just that way
an acid is much more general even than
that and acid is
any species anything that accepts a pair
of electrons remember
lewis was all about those electrons in
the octets
and the base is any species that can
donate a pair of electrons
so lewis correctly took a much more
general view and said no acids and bases
are not even about proton transfer
they're about electron transfer
and again you're i'm not going to test
you on lewis acids and bases but i
wanted you to have that kind of full
picture that means by the way
aluminum three plus take an aluminum
atom make it a three plus
it wants electrons it's an acid
it's an acid right it doesn't have a
protein it wants electrons though
that makes it an acid according to lewis
so
that concludes acids and bases and
i'll see you guys on wednesday
you